you need to bet on your strength knowing
your strength show them their strengths
work on the strength cultivate my spirit
recognize your own strength knows how to
play to their strengths your strenght
playing hello believe nation today we're
going to look at how you can bet on your
strength and as always guys if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired and when you write it down
yourself it's much more likely to stick
with you as well enjoy you need to bet
on your strengths and don't give a about
what you suck at you're going to way too
many people in this room are going to
spend the next 30 40 years of their
lives
trying to check the boxes other things
that they're not as good at and that
you're going to waste a lot of time and
news I highly recommend auditing
yourself or if you have no empathy or EQ
or self-awareness then find somebody in
your family or friendship that does and
let them tell you who you are and once
you believe that either for yourself or
someone else told you go directly all
chips all into that because that is the
only possible way in my opinion watching
from the outside that is swimming phrase
that is a very highly likely way of
over-indexing because the truth is if
you want to be an anomaly you've got to
act like one you know like and so that's
it that's what I got so thanks for
having me I think the most important is
knowing your strengths and weaknesses
and knowing what you enjoy doing you
know if you look at it as a job you've
already lost it it's not going to be
your passion and you're going to count
the hours if you look at it as something
you love to do um and then you know what
your strengths are then you can leverage
those strengths in your business and in
helping others and once you recognize
your weaknesses then you can work with
people that complement you I mean every
one of my businesses I've had a partner
who's very anal Martin Woodall Todd
Wagner incredibly anal people
perfectionist because I'm a slob you
know I'm a
big picture think about what's around
the corner how is technology going to
change things how can I change you know
this industry and you know making sure
that there's somebody there to make to
dot the i's cross the t's and keep me in
the bass lines elm and you know
recognizing my weaknesses is just as
important as recognizing my strengths my
core competencies and and you know
having a passion to do so when you meet
new talent emerging talent and you're
mentoring them if what if you don't have
a confidence that they have the level of
talent required to achieve greatness how
do you counsel them do you say to make
them feel confident to not rob them of
that moment but also steer them in the
right direction I mean you can't say you
really you're zero by talking to them
understanding what their concerns are
what what sort of self-image they have
and and trying to to show them their
strengths too and if they have some kind
of weakness while trying to you know not
focus on those weaknesses I think in
entertainment an industry that's that's
what works you know you you know your
strengths you milk them you know you you
know your weaknesses you try not to
focus on them so much so that the
audience doesn't focus on them as much
you
remember where your roots are and
remember
where your strengths lie a thing is
especially also important to me and I
always believe these are my strengths
and this is what either in tennis I work
on or these are my strengths in my
personality and this is what's also
maybe people want to see and hear and
feel I think many people always feel
like they have to work on their
weaknesses you know I mean I don't know
how he works in the business world as
much but in any way in in tennis working
on your weaknesses makes maybe an
overall complete player but you won't be
dangerous anymore you know so I think
you can sometimes relate to that in some
businesses as well that's why I like to
work on the strengths and its really
helping throughout my career the thing
that you're most comfortable with that
you do the best but that's what you're
going to do mm-hmm you know like me I've
got strengths when I've got weaknesses I
don't work on my weaknesses I ignore
them and I cultivate my strengths the
level of achievement that we have at
anything is a reflection of how well we
were able to focus on it because the
only thing that's holding you back
is the way you're thinking it's very
important and I also come back to chess
to learn how to recognize your own
strengths and weaknesses this is in fact
the vital part of preparation for a big
match and for anything in life we always
try to study our opponents
we're always tied to try to study the
battlefield we always try to study all
the circumstances surrounding our
venture endeavor but very often we
forget to study ourself and this is very
important because any choice of a ground
for battle or you know type of strategy
we want to employ depends on our
recognition of our strengths and
weaknesses and this is a process of
constant evaluation because life is
changing very fast and our points
looking at our success studying it and
trying to be to be smart and outsmart us
eventually and we can look at the
history and just to find a number of
situations where we the inability to
recognize strengths and weaknesses led
to an eventual
docile a girl boss a girl wants to
someone who I guess takes charge of like
for own life so it's a girl boss or a
guy boss someone who knows their
weaknesses and knows what their
strengths are knows how to play to their
strengths I think there's a lot of
people out there and I've interviewed a
lot of them who my favorite interview
question is name your biggest strength
and your biggest weakness or what you
have to work on and the scariest people
the ones who say like I show up early
it's my biggest weakness or like I work
too much
my biggest weakness and you know
everybody has things that they can
improve upon and I think a world where
everybody is more aware of that is a
good one in a place where people can be
empowered to make choices in their life
rather than throw themselves into places
that they may not inherently be
successful because the world is sold
them some story of what they should be
doing so I guess a girl boss is someone
who is in choice you must begin life and
you must approach life with your
strengths absolutely essential
everyone in schooling very often keeps
on pushing one to focus on what is wrong
with us or tells us what is wrong with
us and there is a very interesting
imaginary story of a rabbit and you must
hear this one the rabbit was enrolled in
a rabbit school and like all rabbits it
could hop very well but could not swim
at the end of the year the rabbit got
high marks in hopping but failed in
swimming the parents were concerned the
relations were concerned the friends
were concerned the elder friends
particularly they said forget about
hopping you anyway good at it you don't
have to keep practicing it concentrate
on your filling
and they send the rabbit for tuitions
and coaching in swimming and guess what
happened the rabbit forgot how to hop as
for swimming have you ever seen a rabbit
swim while it is important for us to
know what we are not good at we must
cherish what is good enough it's very
fundamental to life that is because it
is only on our strengths that can give
us the energy to correct our weaknesses
I think it's one of our strengths I mean
there are there are strengths of being a
big corporation would all the resources
you have a tan but there are also
strength for a small founder driven
sports car company that we have to
utilize to compensate for the lack of
size thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
was your paper clip what resonated the
most with you what are you going to take
from this video and immediately apply to
your life or your business somehow
please leave it down in the comments I'm
super curious to find out thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon